à son apogée les presque 300 employés de
l'usiné spérian à plaintel non loin de
saint brieuc produisait 200 millions de
masques chaque année mais depuis deux
ans plus rien l entreprise a fermé ses
portes faute de commandes
un épilogue qui s'apparente à un
véritable gâchis selon nadia
représentante du personnel à l'époque
oui c'était du gâchis quoi alors ça
aurait pu continuer à nager le relais
locaux on avait les machines on a vu
tout alors que maintenant faut trouver
des machines et des locaux en tant que
ça je pense c'est faisable
je suis très optimiste mais aujourd'hui
la situation a bien changé face à
l'épidémie de kovy 19 de reprise de
l'activité de l'usiné sérieusement
envisagée
d'anciens salariés sont en ce moment
même en train de plancher sur un plan de
reprise qui représente un véritable
espoir selon mathieu nicole secrétaire
général pour l'union départementale cgt
des côtes d'armor
ça représente beaucoup d'espoir des gens
en matière de création d'emplois mais
surtout pour l'utilité collective que
tout le monde a bien capté depuis le
début de la crise du coronavirus c'est
que le manque de masques en france et
que ici à quelques années il ya un outil
de production très efficace qui a été
lamentablement détruits c'est un projet
qui équipe qui est très intéressant et
qui peut donc du coup bas palier on va
dire ou à la carence de masques que l'on
connaît depuis le début d'épidémie dans
la ville de plaintel la nouvelle d'une
probable reprise de l'activité est
accueillie avec enthousiasme
tous les habitants reconnaissent
l'importance de la production de masques
et loue le retour d'une entreprise qui a
fait les beaux jours de l'agglomération
c'est important c'est même essentiel de
par ma profession où moi je suis
infirmière libérale donc je manque de
masques je suis j'ai changé mes masques
normalement tous les trois heures c'est
impossible voilà en plus ça va créer
l'emploi
donc ouais c'est super important
j'espère que les pouvoirs publics ne
feront pas deux fois la même erreur et
que il ya certains pans de l'économie
qui sont dépenses stratégiques et les
masques en font partie je suis
directrice d'école sur la commune de
plaintel et je trouve que c'est très
important pour l'attractivité de notre
territoire et
je trouve que pour dynamiser la commune
de plaintel d'avoir de nouveaux parents
des nouveaux enfants ça permettrait
d'avoir de nouveaux enfants aussi sur
sur la commune de plantes est un projet
soutenu par la région qui a reçu un feu
vert du gouvernement le 22 avril dernier
lors d'une visite des manuels maquereau
en bretagne pour relancer l'activité
l'ex directeur de l'usiné lui n'a pas
attendu
il est déjà au travail depuis plusieurs
semaines les choses semblent plutôt bien
avancé
j'espère qu'ils aient de bonnes chances
que le projet aboutisse et donc
aujourd'hui je suis assez confiant je
m'étais engagé vis-à-vis de la région à
fournir un projet business plan crédible
et démontrant la faisabilité
je pense qu'on va y arriver et justement
la situation pourrait évoluer plus vite
que prévu ce mardi en investisseur
libano suisse se dit prêt à faire
revivre lusine de masques nous ne
pouvons pas être dépendant d'un pays
lointain comme le dit le président
macron il faut relocaliser certaines
productions en europe en france et
pourquoi pas en bretagne
nous considérons qu'il est d'une grande
importance de reprendre les anciens
personnels de plaintel dont la
compétence est très importante
l'intérêt de cette activité réside dans
les personnels qui ont leurs
savoir-faire leurs compétences plus que
dans le site
ce sont donc 15 millions d'euros qui
pourraient être investis dans les
prochaines semaines il ne resterait plus
qu'à trouver des locaux la ville de
ploufragan et l'ancien site de
l'entreprise chaffoteaux semble tout
indiqué